personality politics seems to work for
some politicians and then again it backs
fires for others good afternoon
yes it was interesting to see in that
package Jeremy Corbyn being described in
distinction to the other Labour
candidates is not being bland it's right
to say that it's easy to build a base of
support when you have a very different
message a very different approach from
the other candidates and and Corbin
through a mixture of his his somewhat
retro approach to labour values and what
he's been saying these big statements
about reen analyzing the banks and
various parts of our utilities is
definitely cutting through where other
politicians don't and we see as well in
America the the charisma of or at least
the personality of Donald Trump cutting
through with Republican voters and
standing out from a crowded field it's
what politicians can use to gain some
popularity but unfortunately tends to
backfire it tends to be very divisive
when it comes to general elections when
bigger groups of people get to vote and
floating voters and people who might not
typically vote for that party they might
find those candidates quite marmite like
quite divisive and that's probably what
people who are trying to stop Jeremy
Corbyn from winning are worried about I
guess that's the thing isn't it you know
when it comes down to the crunch if it
when somebody's in the voting booth
they're not going to be thinking about
the personality of the candidates it's
ultimately what's in their interest and
and what is in the best interest of the
country
sometimes personality helps it's helped
some politicians getting over stumbles
there are some politicians out there who
we now know and love and typically
they're the ones we can just name with
with just their first or last name like
Boris or Nigel who could really get away
with murdering someone in the street
such as the level of popularity that is
that they sustain and it almost as part
of their character just as with Donald
Trump it's part of his character to say
really outrageous and outlandish things
nobody would be surprised if tomorrow
Jeremy Corbyn said that Britain's food
industry should be realized or
nationalized indeed for the first time
because it would just be part of who
they are they become almost unshockable
or unshockable to the extent that they
can attract voters to pay attention to
them and maybe forgive them a lot of
things that slightly bland on
once politicians could never be allowed
to get away with and that's the danger
for people who are trying to stop that
kind of charismatic but quite
monochromatic quite one-dimensional form
of politics from succeeding and I guess
in other dangers there is the idea for
perhaps alienating a large portion of
the potential electorate if you do
become a caricature for yourself if you
do move from one extreme to another yes
it's exactly the thing that attracts I
mean a lot of young people to Jeremy
Corbyn the idealism that very clear
distinct message but those people who
have been around the block a bit and
seen these arguments tried and tested
and seen the way in which often the the
reality and the the solution to a
political problem is much more nuanced
and complex to become quite frustrated
by those those charismatic individuals
who try to push things through on the
basis of either one simple idea or the
force of their personality in their
image because those people tend to
stumble when they get there and looking
at politics here at home do you see
personality politics being a thing that
will continue into the future given the
fact that we do have 24-hour news given
the fact that we do have social media
there's 24 hours coverage constantly yes
of course because it's the thing that
most easily allows politicians in a
lineup to stand out from each other it's
the reason why Donald Trump could argue
against a whole sweep of Republican
candidates in last night's Republican
debate he stands out he gives a clear
message and people need that name
recognition when they're in politics
because most people don't pay a lot of
attention to politics they pay attention
very briefly when it comes to elections
and that name recognition is invaluable
so they'll always be a focus on the
personalities of our leaders and
hopefully it'll be tempered with some
respect and appreciation for their ideas
and for their policies but it's always
going to be part of why we are
interested in why we sit up and pay
attention to the people who want to lead
us